Okay, let's begin to wrap things up with a few final recommendations.
And we'll begin with project organization.
As demonstrated in this slide, there are levels and sublevels that allow for better organization
and collaborative compartmentalization.
So your environment or your persistent level will contain anything that is universally
shared within the entire project.
Project sets, environments, or discipline-specific setups can live on their own sublevels and
to clarify, when I'm talking about levels, I'm referring to maps or worlds.
I do not mean level sequences.
There is a difference between these two assets.
Levels get organized into sublevels and live under your persistent level depending on what
is actually needed for your project or department.
For example, your main lighting setup should live on your persistent level, as it will
be utilized by the entire project or production.
Any level sequence-specific lighting setups should live in a sequencer lighting comp's
sublevel, so that anything specific to the level sequence that is spawnable can be connected
to that specific sublevel.
That way, the lights in that level sequence can be called in and out without affecting
the persistent level and causing problems between users working within that persistent
level by having the sequencer-specific lighting turn on or off when the sublevel containing
those lights is not active.
Additionally, you can also create level visibility tracks in Sequencer that allow you to turn
on and off the visibility of the assets in each of those sublevels so that they don't
always have to be active.
Now, I want to take a moment to emphasize just how important project organization is.
Without it, things can get really messy very fast, so I highly recommend creating nested
folder structures inside your content browser and inside your outliner to maintain project
organization as you work.
Another important factor in organizing level sequences is that actors within a level sequence
can be divided into one of two categories, possessable and spawnable.
Possessable actors are intended to be possessed by each level sequence that calls them into
use, but ultimately, these actor types belong to the level and are actively in that level
the entire time.
Spawnable actors exist within the unique level sequence to which they belong and then disappear
when that level sequence is outside of its play range or no longer active.
Basically, spawnable is like pulling a book down from a bookshelf, reading the instructions
and then putting it back in to be used again later when needed.
Now, each of these can prove beneficial depending on your needs and workflows, but one of the
things to note is that the EPO storyboard tools do not currently support spawnable actors
at this time.
Now, continuing our discussion about project organization, I want to point out that level
sequences can also be deeply nested within each other.
So let's jump into the engine and take a look at what that means.
Now, if we look in the Content Browser inside Unreal Engine, under the Courses folder, you'll
find in the 20501 folder under Course Topics, there is another folder called seqshortex.
Inside that folder, you'll find an seqfilm level sequence that if you double click on,
you'll find that this level sequence has been set up to contain subnested level sequences
that can break down the film into sequences and sequences into shots.
Also, shots can be varied thanks to Sequencer's Take system.
In practice, this works by creating duplicate shots of any shot in your level sequence,
as long as they live together in the same folder.
For us, seqscene1shots, there are three variations inside their scene1shot folder.
If I move over to the Sequencer timeline and right click on this particular shot, I can
go and move up to the takes and choose any of those three existing takes that are all
different from each other because I've modified the animation, lighting, or even the staging
of any actor within that shots level sequence.
Now another actor class that has a profound impact on setting up action in Unreal Engine
is the use of a subscenes track.
A subscene essentially references an existing level sequence for the express purpose of
layering multiple actions together.
This type of organization allows you to create a departmentalized level sequence organization
so that teams of artists can work together in real time to construct distinct portions
of the action-based department or discipline that can be utilized in conjunction with sublevel organization.
Just as we discussed for the lighting scenarios, cinematography can also do this for cine cameras.
Character animation can have its own subscene, so all your characters and animations can
live on an animation-specific sublevel as well.
Level blueprints or level sequence blueprints, level sequence specific effects, anything
that could be spotable or triggered can also live on a sublevel under the persistent level
and also be organized in Sequencer through subscenes.
One thing to note is that while subscene organization works well for most departmental organization,
it does not work very well with storyboarding tools at this time.
Attempting to use a subscene for storyboards will cause Unreal Engine to crash.
Finally, when working with animation in Sequencer, you might find it helpful to create folders
for assets inside Sequencer to keep the event manager tidy.
Or groups for assets while animating.
Just be aware that the groups window does not dock to any part of Unreal Engine, so
you will need to keep this window open.
Oh, one more thing.
When animating or working in Unreal Engine, you can use the F10 key to isolate selected
control rig controls or isolate any tab you have active in the engine.
F10 acts as a toggle, so if you accidentally dock all your tabs, don't worry.
Just hit F10 again to restore your viewport and remember, try to work non-destructively
by duplicating an animation asset before making major changes.
Alright, that's it for this section.
In our next section, we'll continue with more of our final recommendations.